this is really funny um we spoke uh
we've been speaking this week and we're
going to speak again
in fact about how the world is
increasingly ignoring donald trump media
outlets are focused on the biden
transition
world leaders are welcoming joe biden as
president-elect despite
donald trump not having conceded the
election
this is just amazing british prime
minister boris johnson who i'm not a fan
of politically to be very clear
boris johnson yesterday started
referring to donald trump as the
previous president even though donald
trump still does have a couple months
left
in his presidency and also said it was
refreshing to speak to
president-elect joe biden which is just
perfect and hilarious and if you
if you adjust for british humor and
british temperament
talking about it being refreshing to
speak to joe biden referring to trump as
the previous president
it's pretty spicy stuff let's take a
look and also really funny that the
statement from boris johnson was in
response to a question
from labor mp angela eagle and in her
question to boris johnson angela eagle
couches uh trump's refusal to concede
as embarrassing and dangerous to
american democracy both accurate but
that's the premise and nobody even
thinks to argue with the premise because
of course it's accurate take a look at
this
the prime minister spoke for many of us
when he took a call yesterday to
congratulate president-elect
biden and vice president elect harris on
their emphatic win
in the u.s presidential election so does
the prime minister now have any advice
for his erstwhile best friend president
trump whose continuing refusal to accept
the result
is both embarrassing for him and
dangerous for american
democracy prime minister well uh mr
speaker i had
uh and have a good relationship with the
previous president i
i do not resile uh from that is the duty
of all british prime ministers have a
good relationship
with the white house uh but i'm i i'm
delighted
uh to find the many areas uh in which
uh the biden the incoming biden harris
administration
uh is able to make common cause with us
it's just hilarious
how donald trump hasn't even conceded
but
in either case trump does have the
presidency for two more months
and the british prime minister is
referring to trump as the previous
president
and calling his conversation with the
president-elect
who trump still has not acknowledged as
refreshing now
he may not have meant much by it but
it's poetic
in that much of the world already is
thinking of trump
as the previous president trump is doing
no presidential things
trump has not done any actual
presidential work for months now he's
been campaigning for months
now he's sulking in his office calling
allies and friends and seeing can
anybody give me any encouraging or good
news and we'll be reporting on that a
little bit later based on
philip rucker's great reporting but
world leaders are just moving on and i
was actually thinking
that all of these discussions about
could donald
trump execute a coup how might donald
trump
execute a coup all of that which we've
been talking about i still maintain my
position that
the answer is a simple no the latest
claims
including from peter alexander from nbc
are that even trump knows
excuse me even trump knows that he has
no shot at this coup
but that one of the things that will
make it even tougher to steal the white
house if trump tried
is that the world is already looking at
joe biden as if he's president
but ultimately trump failing to steal
the white house
will still have a big impact because
trump
could still delegitimize biden in the
minds of the
al-qaeda types as we call them all over
the country
such that they remain angry throughout
biden's presidency
and obviously that carries with it
significant risk
i don't think trump has a master plan i
don't think trump is some kind of evil
genius where he's trying to radicalize
his supporters to never acknowledge
biden as the rightful president
and maybe even do violence or whatever i
just think trump doesn't want to lose
but trump continuing to do this even if
he doesn't believe that there's a shot
at overturning the election which
the latest reporting is he doesn't
really believe it there could be a
significant holdover impact beyond
january 20th and as i referred to
earlier
trump has already convinced 86 of his
voters
that joe biden did not legitimately win
that is
stunning and so trump's plan simply is
an
ego narcissism plan it's the same
playbook he's used his entire life never
mind his entire presidency
blame other people deny that you failed
never apologize never admit defeat
divide
people get people mad and scared and
angry
exaggerate everything that's his plan
but it can have an impact on his
followers and world leaders dealing with
biden as president-elect
is a good thing to push back against
that although it's not like
trump supporters are really willing to
see reason right now
and unfortunately i mean tragically for
the country many of them are never going
to see reason which is why it's
important that joe biden do everything
he can
to just move ahead appoint adults to
positions of power
and that's exactly what joe biden
announced last night with his chief of
staff and i want to talk about that next
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale
on all of their products right now and
you can take advantage of it by going to
davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality wrist
swatch
really is the perfect way to add
something
fresh to your style whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else
vincero is a brand that has a serious
dedication to the craft
of watchmaking which is really evident
when you look closely at their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black
watch and i love the sleek minimalist
design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wrist watch from
high-end materials but one that everyday
people can afford
and that's why they have over 25
thousand
five star reviews because you won't find
a better made
watch for this great of a price anywhere
else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video